et nous voici donc de retour sur le
plateau de guyancourt en direct si vous
nous suivez aux alentours de 18h15 nous
allons parler à présent de l'actualité
du jour à commencer par la politique
échec de françois bayrou retrait de la
candidature d'hervé morin et de
jean-louis borloo la présidentielle et
législatives ont été difficiles pour les
centristes et pour certains plus que
d'autres j'accueille sur ce plateau
pierre leguérinel bonsoir exploit alors
vous êtes l'ancien secrétaire général
adjoint du modem au niveau national est
aujourd'hui responsable régional de
l'alliance centriste
vous avez changé d'étiquette changer de
formation politique vous avez quittez
donc françois bayrou pour jean arthuis
pourquoi ce changement
d'abord parce qu'il ya deux raisons la
première c'est que j'ai tenu mes
engagements
il y avait une date j'avais vu il ya dix
ans françois bayrou et sachant que dans
ce pays il faut souvent avoir beaucoup
perdu pour espérer gagner lui même
disait mais la troisième fois sera la
bonne donc je m'étais engagé à rester
avec lui jusqu'à la troisième fois la
troisième fois est passé ça veut dire
que vous quittez le cerveau l'aiment
parce qu'elle coule non ça veut dire que
moi j'ai suivi un homme parce que je lui
trouvaient du charisme que sa tentative
à trois fois échoué
peut-être espère-t-il qui en aura une
autre moi je considère j'ai tenu mon
engagement
comment vous expliquer cet échec tout de
même du modem de ses candidates leur
rang soit 0 16e édition pendant
l'entre-deux-tours aussi parce qu'il ya
une deuxième raison me demander quelles
étaient mes raisons et je crois que la
deuxième va la seconde va répondre à
votre question
françois bayrou il a réussi un assez
magistrale tour de force mais pour
partie involontaire c'est que de l'udf
il avait la possibilité de construire
une grande famille politique nouvelle et
pour un certain nombre de raisons qui
lui sont pas largement tout imputable ce
fut un échec
ce mouvement à mes yeux n'est pas un
parti politique je laisse longtemps
pensé et donc comme il y avait mon
engagement je suis resté d'ailleurs sans
jamais insulter ceux qui partaient ce
qui fait la différence parfois avec
d'autres ça n'est pas un parti politique
parce qu'un parti politique ça ne sert
pas seulement à promouvoir un homme ça
sert à vouloir gagner les élections les
élections parce que l'ambition de tout
politique c'est rendre le pouvoir pour
mettre en place ses idées
or ce mouvement ce qu'il fallait surtout
pas parler de partie ce mouvement a à
mon avis à peu près tout fait ce qu'il
fallait pour perdre toutes les élections
les unes derrière les autres
vous vous en êtes expliqué avec françois
bayrou vous lui avait fait part je somme
il est très difficile de discuter de ce
sujet avec françois est ce que ce que je
comprends pas ce que chaque fois c'est
un vrai déchirement puis c'est une
remise en cause de ce qui est sa
stratégie tron je vais vous donner un
exemple simple à la dernière
présidentielle même si le score est pas
bon il fait trois fois plus que la
candidate écologiste
si j'ai bonne mémoire les écologistes
ont un groupe parlementaire à
l'assemblée nationale yvan un groupe
parlementaire au sénat ils ont des élus
dans les régions ils ont des élus locaux
j'aimerais qu'on me dise où en sont les
gens que j'ai côtoyés pendant longtemps
à part ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas fait
ce que fait tous partie
on s'est refusé à discuter par avance
pour faire des alliances
ça c'est un péché mortel on va parler
donc de votre stratégie pour l'avenir
puisque vous avez changé de formation
l'alliance centriste on va juste écouté
pendant un instant l'euro mazaury c'est
le porte parole du modem dans le
département comment ils accueillent
votre départ sa réaction
pire le guérinel après a fait un long
chemin avec le modem y compris avec
l'udf à l'époque il faut pas oublier
qu'il vient de l'udf retrouve je dirais
une voix qui était déjà la sienne c'est
à dire celle du centre droit plutôt que
celle d'un centre totalement est
pleinement indépendant pour le coup et
au delà de cela ce n'est pas une manière
à nous choquer ça nous semble logique
avec sa trajectoire et puis après tout
les centres reste composantes du centre
donc pour nous ça nous pose pas de
problème particulier bien au contraire
on retrouve cela dans la logique de sa
décision individuelle comme celle
d'ailleurs qui avait pris françois
bayrou en soutenant françois hollande
c'était une décision individuelle dont
bruce n'est pas une trahison est
d'ailleurs rejoint de l'alliance
centriste est toujours resté au centre
donc ce n'est pas une trahison divorce à
l'amiable
tout va bien j'ai jamais eu le sentiment
d'avoir divorcé mais si c'est à
l'amiable c'est d'autant mieux non mais
je le disais tout à l'heure sans sourire
moi j'ai vu au fil des années partir
beaucoup de gens qui avaient été des
amis politiques
jamais je n'ai insultés lemoine d'entre
eux jamais je n'ai coupé les ponts ce
qui fait que j'ai encore beaucoup de
contacts avec les anciens et je crois
que c'est bien je crois que c'est bien
et laurent vient dire quelque chose qui
est essentiel
les trajectoires individuelles elles
sont forcément amené à se regrouper et à
se recouper parce que c'est ça ou la
disparition du centre voilà je crois que
l'objectif aujourd'hui il est à peu près
lisible par tout le monde
donc vous êtes maintenant du côté de
l'alliance centriste vous imaginez
peut-être trouvé le modem au sein d'une
nouvelle famille politique lui dit
l'union des démocrates et indépendants
congrès fondateur prévue le 21 octobre
est au tour de jean louis borloo
l'alliance centriste va en faire partie
les centristes on est parties prenantes
pleinement aux une dynamique est en
train de se construire dans qu'elle se
construit sur la base des divers
mouvements trop nombreux qui était la
caractéristique de cet éparpillement
si c'est pas une formation de plus une
formation au centre et de plus c'était
donc qu'elle est là je dire le moins
c'est qu'on puisse faire avec mais
l'objectif très clair c'est qu'à terme
on retrouve soit sous une forme
confédéral soit une fédération ce qui
serait mieux
quelque chose de profondément unitaire
oui bien sûr et je vous parliez du modem
qu'est ce que vont faire les eaux et les
autres ça revient en conscience à chacun
ce qu'ils ont envie de faire de la
réflexion politique de la réflexion
c'est très honorable
ils vont rester sous une forme quasi
associative enfers de la réflexion ceux
qui ont envie de faire de la politique
active par exemple à l'échelle locale ce
qui est quand même le cas de beaucoup
je crois que ils n'ont pas beaucoup le
choix est d'ailleurs je serais pas
surpris que dans les prochains mois on
s'aperçoive que on va se retrouver
nombreux dans un lieu alors que nous
venions de familles différentes ou pas
d'ailleurs formation politique
indépendante lui dit oui
la future une haie ou plutôt centre
droit alors attendez moi si j'ai suivi
aussi longtemps françois bayrou c'est
parce que claire mort j'avais le
sentiment que il fallait construire une
stratégie d'indépendance certainement
pas une stratégie d'isolement son sacre
au terme de dix ans j'ai quand même fini
par craquer se retrouver seul en
expliquant qu'on est les meilleurs
c'est possible mais si vous n'êtes un
modèle pour personne ça ne va pas bien
loin
alors plutôt à droite appelé tour à
gauche alain en fonction des positions
en fonction des situations
alors d'abord ça peut être très
différent selon les situations des
niveaux d'élections à l'échelle locale
moi j'ai toujours dit j'ai appris à
montigny pendant longtemps est quelqu'un
qui intégrait régulièrement dans sa
liste des gens qui étaient dans son
opposition de gauche précédemment je
pense que c'est intelligent à l'échelle
locale les problèmes sont pas des
problèmes de
stratosphérique idéologique c'est pas ça
c'est traiter des questions exemple ça
moi mon souci si je n'arrive pas à le
régler en plus c'est comment franchi le
pont qui mène de maurepas à la gare de
la verrière en moins de 20 minutes le
matin ce que vous croyez franchement il
faut être de gauche ou de droite pour
régler ça fait tendance est un problème
qui vous préoccupe
puisque vous êtes alors en revanche oui
pour des élections qui ont des enjeux de
nature différente
les positionnements ça compte moi j'ai
aucun souci à faire alliance avec une
partie de la gauche raisonnable
je suis pas sûr qu'elles le soient
encore en ce moment où avec une partie
de la droite républicaine et d'ailleurs
si vous le permettez juste une roma si
les centristes en vraiment un enjeu
c'est aujourd'hui pourquoi parce qu'on
assiste à un double mouvement ça va
donner raison paradoxalement françois
bayrou mais trop tard c'est que la
gauche se radicalise
alors que moi j'espérais qu'un
personnage comme françois hollande avait
la capacité à moderniser la gauche
française jeu pas très sûr ce soit le
cas
quand je dis ça c'est que même c'est une
litote je suis perdue persuadé du
contraire
en tout cas il y échoue pour l'instant
et quant à la droite on voit bien dans
la candidature au sein de l'ump entre
françois fillon jean françois copé le
second radicalise son discours pour
marcher sur les territoires du front
national cet aspect là ne m'intéresse
pas et de ce que j'entends au sein de ce
qui va constituer du délit c'est pas ça
qui nous intéresse
maintenant si c'est travailler avec des
gens qui sont républicaines au motif
qu'ils sont taxés à droite c'est pas un
dessin en moi j'assume les alliances de
ce type
je veux qu'on me ferais reproche dans
certains cas lors des alliances de cette
nature là alors quand on attendu souvent
la main à la gauche françois l'a fait
françois bayrou c'est pas la main qui
l'a reçu dans la figure mais c'est la
porte
voilà ça c'est assez indigne on peut pas
à la fois dire on vous veut mais c'est
complètement à nos conditions en même
temps la position du modem a pas
toujours été très claire restoux
l'accord plutôt à droite
forcément après en interne j'ai souvent
été critiqués vite et de le dire
l'extérieur c'est pas bien saviez
formule de chevènement ascom les
ministres où on est d'accord
c lin d'oeil si on n'est pas d'accord on
le dit ou on ferme sa gueule ou on s'en
va
bon moi j'avais pas les choisir farc
alors j'ai choisi aujourd'hui cette
entité en disant ça fait un bail qu'on
même que pensez-vous du rassemblement
des centres c'est la question que nous
sommes allez vous poser aujourd'hui dans
les rues de saint quentin en
écoutez toute façon ils ont toujours été
ils ont tous été plus ou moins du
centre-droit en toute façon le modem
alors tu seras proche du nouveau parti
de borloo a créé ça ne me surprend pas
écouter ce que j'emporte son terrain à
l'avenir un ca vient d'être fait donc
atteindre aulas moi je fais pas beaucoup
de politiques 1 je trouve qu'ils sont
tous dans le même dans le même sens et
ils font tous pareil alors voilà le
centre il n'a jamais mené la danse le
centre le centre
ils sont modérés ils sont sympathiques
mais pour gagner
si ça sera dur même rassemblé ça sera
dur on quand on parle de rassemblement
c'est toujours ça fait du bien c'est
toujours quelque chose de positif
et puis on espère que ça ira
aujourd'hui il ya des gens dans le
centre à la gauche il ya des gens du
centre qui sont à droite donc peut-être
faire un parti en pour que chacun puisse
vraiment donner ses idées en étant tout
au centre mais je pense que la france
est au centre à la base donc et ce
rassemblement des centres du centre
passera peut-être par l'ue des ide oncle
udi congrès fondateur prévue le 21
octobre
vous êtes chargé au niveau régional de
l'alliance centriste qui sera partie
intégrante donc de cette u10 portées par
jean-louis borloo
les prochaines étapes au niveau
départemental en tout cas pour lui dit
il ya déjà des mises en place qui
tissent au fond oui j'étais à une
réunion dans l'essonne il y a quelques
jours les choses se passent bien
j'espère qu'il en ira de même dans les
yvelines
il y a les gens suffisamment avertis
intéressé entreprenant pour construire
quelque chose qui ait du sens
voyez l'histoire ça passe vite une des
personnes que vous interrogez vidéo mais
le centre ça jamais été au fond
la machine de pouvoir qui se souvient
que la france de valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est pas loupé de l'humanité
la plupart des grands élus était
centriste et dans ce département
quasiment tous les élus étaient udf donc
ce qui fut peut au moins partiellement
redevenir il faut être à la fois
ambitieux et raisonnable et dans les
premières réunions en tout cas juste
pour conclure qu'ils ont eu lieu pour
lui dit pour cette union des centres
dans le département fédère toutes les
formations du centre
est-ce que vous avez retrouvé des
anciens camarades il m oui je les ai ah
bah écoutez j'ai retrouvé plus que ça
parce que moi j'ai commencé à passer des
coups de fil à sonder les uns et les
autres en commençant par des élus que je
connaissais qui ont été avec moi l'udf
ou pas qui était nouveau centre modem et
pour l'instant je veux dire que je vais
vous faire un aveu terrible tout ce que
j'appelle y en a un qui m'a dit je
demande à voir
mais tous les autres ont dit oui et ce
sera donc le 21 octobre en tout cas pour
le congrès fondateur de cette idée merci
pierre leguay et donc nouveau
responsable en ile-de-france de
l'alliance centriste